we got surprise a surprise ah Paracelsus
oh my goodness he's gonna be really
excited you're my undead come here
faster faster oh my favorite
no oh I'm into you this is heavy and
cold oh it's open it buddies no way this
is great I make like a gummies
whoa are they Lego gummies haha
are these are don't gummies what does
that mean yeah oh my god great they look
so good sure they do taste big oh great
we try them Allison made good hey laser
woman
that's what I was asking adult that's
nice
[Music]
all right I actually didn't film
anything today except something I don't
remember what it was but I feel I feel
something somebody's a secret little
pooper we found that out today we also
played this game called assassin work I
don't even know how to explain it and
how do you play the game
one person is an assassin and only that
person knows that they're the assassin
so everyone else is trying to guess who
that person is
hmm pick one person to kill and if
they're wrong the next day if I'm fake
sleeping those daily sassing kills
overnight and they wake up there's
another dead body so if they figure out
again and they trying to guess who the
assassin is and it's with cards so like
we'd be like oh this is the killer and
I'm doing short fras you could do it
with little pieces of paper let's say
you're a assassin or your regular
personal Justine did you the shame was
well no but I've actually I don't ever
get mad but I felt actual anger rage
tonight and I didn't like it I didn't
like it at all we like this I had fun
them if you're ever in court you're
gonna lose because whoever accuses you
of anything uh yours like no but no no
the argument that I have is real
high-pitched and yeah you could go to
court tomorrow and try it yes definitely
get it accused of something I just
definitely a good lawyer okay yeah yeah
all right but I think somebody was if I
ever did Matt's reward a cute little man
a second girl don't do it do it I were
heading up we made it back late last
night Lake Arrowhead and
back to the car now heading to the
airport we love our parents this is kind
of crazy because they they basically
have never really travel they travel we
always drive places and they hopped on a
plane we are actually picking them up at
LAX
I don't know I bilberry has really big
dreams of
how's that song I forget that the plane
at LAX with a dream in a cardigan card
the dog is here I'm not happy with this
safety harness situation right now
that's going on in here for the car I'm
driving a bus I am driving the los
angeles los you are be being look at you
this is not this is nothing if I have to
figure out a different car reservation
for him I don't like this I don't like
my baby being just free rein he's
attached to a harness but it's all safe
how's it yeah when we add LAX and if
you've never been to this Airport it is
a kind of exact I know your breathe they
don't are Jenna what's your name we
don't available as yet you can never
wait at the airport I'll go down here
don't sign here okay Jenna can you film
what's happening right now huh
yeah I'm not really sure with a say the
dog is here I'm here there's not enough
room in the back for all the luggage so
I have to sit in this little teeny tiny
seat it's gonna be alright
wait write me space for luggage bring me
luggage
this is gray okay the self only know
so safer day came to the girls today
he's gonna get clean
hey sturdy and rewarding she's Kate
factoring I'm buying a couch ah love The
Cheesecake Factory all these things are
happening oh my goodness
holy wait I can't get out
it's just a penny switcher
hi I can't oh hey hey no no Maddy no no
no no no is this the same dog no I was
like that it's okay just take it very a
little bit off Oh I mean they took a
little bit off but he is little baby I
was like I think you gave me the
different dog because he said that he
was well behaved I said are you sure
thank you for kisses looking so glad you
don't if one Oh make sure you wait oh my
cute better even good boy oh oh oh hey I
did we're getting a new couch for the
office probably something that Maddy
would like to be on got him this finally
your toy the pig with boots I've been
eyeing it up for so long
okay well I'm going to finish this and
we'll see you soon
I feel like you're basically just doing
a replay of the last time that you were
here we're getting a coffee the Sun is
about to set we cannot miss the
Instagram pic very very very important I
think that brings us vlog to a close as
usual I don't remember what I filmed but
I will tell you that I've got a cute dog
and I'm very excited about it look at
this link it's a little mochi blanket
all buddy you're so sleepy you have such
a hard weekend yeah stay tuned for more
vlogs I'll see you guys soon happy
vlogmas I'm slowing on the failures
[Music]